es ist schon wieder passiert in russland
ist es bei einem raketentest zu einem
atomunfall gekommen fünf menschen
starben
radioaktivität wurden freigesetzt schon
im herbst 2017 hatte sich eine
radioaktive wolke aus dem nichts über
deutschland gelegt damals sprachen nur
in diensten für einen unfall in der
russischen atomfabrik majak beim
aktuellen unfall gibt es informationen
und der vorteil aus 2017 wurde noch
einmal genauer untersucht krieg zum
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
strandes 1 videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nicht herzlich
willkommen und danke für diesen super
spannend themenvorschlag von euch aus
der telegramm community von br peter auf
telegramm bekommt in die videos früher
können diskutieren und themenvorschläge
machen
der link zu unserem telegramm news
service ist hier unter dem ida und in
der video beschreibung
es war anfang oktober 2017 als sich
wetterstationen in ganz europa über
wirklich ungewöhnliche messwerte
wunderten der grund dafür eine
radioaktive wolke aus ruthenium 106
nicht nur in deutschland wurde das
isotopen nachgewiesen sondern auch unter
anderem in griechenland in norwegen in
der ukraine und der schweiz
das radionuklid kommt normalerweise
nicht in der atmosphäre vorsah nachweis
spricht für eine atombombenexplosion
oder eben einen atomunfall bis zu 176
mini becquerel pro kubikmeter luft
wurden damals an einigen messstellen
verzeichnet der höchste wert der nach
tschernobyl je über europa gemessen
wurde dazu der radio ökologe georg
steinhauser aus hannover die messungen
deuten darauf hin dass sie die größte je
gemessene eingriff freisetzung von
radioaktivität aus einer zivilen anlage
war dennoch nach offiziellen
behördenangaben ist diese konzentration
an ruthenium 106 in der luft nicht
gesundheitsschädlich schon damals hatten
unabhängige experten und expertinnen
darauf getippt dass es einen unfall in
einer russischen nuklearanlage im
südlichen ural gegeben haben muss doch
russland werte diesen vorwurf ab niemand
wollte es gewesen sein auch wenn bereits
damals einige indizien auf die russische
nuklearanlage majak hingewiesen hat
dazu georg steinhauser während der
aktuellen studie beteiligt war niemand
berichtete damals über einen atomunfall
und kein lied start der internationalen
atomenergieagentur iaea dazu irgendetwas
über eine mögliche quelle zu wissen
russische offizielle erklärten damals
jedoch dass maja gemischten quelle sein
könne weil man im boden rund um die
anlage keine radio unten im stollen
gefunden habe
stattdessen verwies russland 2017 darauf
dass es sich auch um die radionuklid
batterie eine satelliten handeln könnte
der beim eintritt in die atmosphäre
verglüht ist ein internationales
forschungsteam aus insgesamt 69
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftlern
hat sich jetzt noch einmal 1300
messwerte von stationen in asien europa
genauer angeschaut darunter auch die
konzentration von ruthenium einer 6 in
der atmosphäre und am boden
die ergebnisse der studie legen nahe
dass es im herbst 2017 erhöhten
ruthenium 106 konzentrationen in der
luft mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit doch
auf einem unfall in der russischen
nuklear anlage majak im südlichen ural
zurückzuführen sind übrigens eine der
größten nuklearanlagen der welt hier
wird nicht nur zwischengelagert sondern
auch kernbrennstoffe aufbereitet und
radionuklide hergestellt und 57
ereignete sich hier der bis dahin
tragische atomunfall aller zeiten nach
einer explosion mussten 11.000 menschen
umgesiedelt werden lediglich die beiden
katastrophen von tschernobyl und
fukushima übertrafen diesen vorfall
der unfall vom wagen aus dem 750 wurde
nach der internationalen bewertungsskala
für nukleare ereignisse in die
zweithöchste kategorie eingeordnet es
handelt sich um die kategorie 6 dass es
sich 2017 um die radeon und glied
batterie eines satelliten gar nicht
haben könnte der beim eintritt in die
atmosphäre verglüht ist können die
experten und expertinnen nach ihrer
detaillierten analyse nun sicher
ausschließen denn dies hätte nach
angaben der fachleute zu einer
vertikalen verteilung des roten jungs
106 in der luft geführt doch dies war
nicht der fall auch ein unfall in einem
atomkraftwerk konnten die experten und
expertinnen ausschließen denn dann hätte
man weitere spaltprodukte wie
beispielsweise strontium oder cäsium
aufspüren müssen auch dies war damals
nicht der fall nicht nur die modelle von
luftmassen
bewegung sprechen allerdings dafür dass
sich ein unglück in der atomfabrik mai
ereignet haben muss auch das muster
nachdem sich das material nach und nach
abgelagerter drückt die russische
nuklearanlage ins visier der fachleute
dazu heißt es in der studie
die detektion der helium wolke im
rumänischen 10 sehr am dreißigsten
september 2016 deutet auf eine
freisetzung in majak zwischen
demonstranten september um 18 uhr haben
und dem sextanten september mittags sind
die messungen verraten sogar noch mehr
und zwar legen sie nahe dass das
ruthenium bei der wiederaufbereitung von
kernbrennstoffen freigesetzt wurde
das forschungsteam schreibt den der
neuen studie ausführlich über das
verhältnis von ruthenium 103 und
ruthenium 106 und dieses spricht dafür
dass die stoffe bei der
wiederaufarbeitung von abgebrannten
kernbrennstoffen ausgetreten sind zudem
erlaubt diese analyse den rückschluss
dass das radionuklid aus relativ jungen
brennstäben stammen muss diese sind wohl
bereits nach kurzer abklingzeit
weiterverarbeitet worden was total
untypisch für westliche
wiederaufbereitungsanlagen ist diese
kurze wartezeit könnte laut der neuen
studie darauf hinweisen dass man
möglichst viel cerium 144 gewinnen
wollte einen radionuklid dass die
atomfabrik majak an den neutrino
detector im italienischen gran sasso
laboratorium geliefert hat
möglicherweise kam es also zu einem leck
als man hier in der atomfabrik meyer
radioaktives material für ein experiment
in gran sasso untergrund labor abfüllen
wollte über das labor hammer ja schon
berichtet das ziel war es also
möglicherweise das isotop cerium 144 zu
produzieren mit dessen hilfe im gran
sasso labor unterirdisch
elementarteilchen analysiert werden hier
ist man auf der suche nach dem
mysteriösen neutrinos die zu den größten
rätsel der physik gehören zu diesem
verdacht heißt es in der aktuellen
studie
der auftrag zur lieferung des c
144 wurde von der anlage in mayak
storniert kurz nachdem die freisetzung
des premium aufmerksamkeit erregt hatte
in köln würde man sagen da kannst du
dran förder es spricht also alles dafür
eigentlich gibt es keinen zweifel
trotzdem eindeutige belege dafür dass es
tatsächlich ein unfall in der atomfabrik
meyer gegeben hat liefert die neue
studie von georg steinhausen und seinem
team also nicht dennoch sind die
hinweise darauf mehr als erdrückend
vielleicht hat das damals in der
russischen atomfabrik sogar verletzte
gegeben so die spekulationen des
internationalen forschungsteams dazu
georg steinhauser auch wenn es derzeit
kein offizielles statement dazu gibt es
haben wir eine recht gute idee was
passiert sein könnte und vielleicht weil
in diesem fall durch eine einfache
analyse herausgefunden wurde was
passiert war
spielen die russin beim aktuellen fall
schon fast mit offenen karten zwar wurde
die mitteilung einer sprecherin der
region zwar reddoxx winds inzwischen
gelöscht aber durch sie wissen wir dass
radioaktivität freigesetzt wurde
raketen experten und expertinnen aus den
usa vermuten den test eines neuen
marschflugkörper mit atomantrieb der
schiefgegangen ist noch gibt es keine
details aber wenn dann die atomwolke
sich ausgebreitet haben sollte ja
vielleicht wie beim atomunfall im markt
dann könnten sehr genaue schlüsse daraus
gezogen werden
fünf tote gab es ja auch würde es
eigentlich mit kernfusion keine solchen
tragischen atomunfälle mehr geben wie
funktioniert kernfusion cedric von
doktor watson erklärt wie es geht hier
anklicken anschauen und dem megacoolen
kanal doktor watson abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran